being a part of something like this
there's a tremendous thing Browdy
[Music]
morning sergeant
gentlemen whoever's making these has an
answer for the deaths of 24 American
soldiers in the past 12 months and every
day we don't find them is another day an
American soldier could come home in
pieces and wants to make a difference
hey Jeff things are really taking off
for me so do you like it cooked
bloody caveman go gentlemen what's the
play relationship-building starting new
series who's ready to have some fun
I just keep thinking about that kid that
we killed today we think it's wrong
yeah I do you kill one of theirs you
save ten of ours you're telling me
that's not right
he's up now listen he didn't deserve to
die her cooperation Andrew tell me
what's going on
you know that anything that happens to
have your stakes in the family a favor
go get the targets do you think we're
gonna shoot you or something
you're trying to do what you think is
right the problem is you don't even know
what right means leave me alone you are
alone do I do the right thing and put
myself in danger or did I just shut up
and deal with it you give me your
loyalty and I guarantee that each and
every one of you will have a chance to
be a warrior to actually be a part of
history
ready on three three two one
[Applause]
you